c'est officiel hein donc on le sait tous
Gabriel hatal est notre nouveau Premier
ministre mais saviez-vous qu'il aé il a
aussi été le premier à assumer
publiquement son homosexualité lundi
soir sur LCI une séquence qui a fait
énormément réagir un intervenant qui
s'appelle Guillaume roquet qui est
toujours dans des salades pas
possibles excellent c'est
excellent excellent merci bien directeur
de la rédaction du Figaro Magazine qui a
expliqué que la nomination de Gabriel
Attal à Matignon sera en partie du à son
homosexualité c'est comme si on disait
que la nomination de Gill Verdez
porte-parole des chroniqueurs était dû à
sa coiffure n'importe quoi regardez et
il avait dit déjà d'ailleurs bien
longtemps avant que euh son voilà son
homosexualité faisait partie de sa vie
et de ce qu'il était et je pense que
c'est c'est un un un des des des
éléments parmi d'autres mais qu'il ne
faut pas négliger dans ce qui pourrait
être le choix du président de la
République l'un des leviers de l'action
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est l'émancipation
c'est-àdire l'idée que on doit être
libre libre de construire sa vie libre
de faire ses choix et en cela là Gabriel
Atal par ses choix son orientation
sexuelle est un un le reflet de cette de
cette liberté et de cette émancipation
voulu par Emmanuel Macron alors tout le
monde lui est tombé dessus est-ce que
vous trouvez ça normal
ou est-ce qu' il s'est excusé après hein
bah oui par c'est une analyse
complètement débile par c'est pas parce
qu'il met un costume et une cravate qui
peut dire n'importe quoi ce n'est pas
pertinent de parler de la sexualité du
nouveau Premier ministre et hier
regardez on a fait une séquence de 20 ou
30 minutes sur lui à aucun moment on a
parlé de ça et je trouve bah oui mais je
trouve que c'est bien il y a plein de
médias qui en ont parlé et est-ce que le
la fin de l'homophobie ce n'est pas tout
simplement de ne en
parler il
magineopi je trouve que c'est bien qu'il
se félicite mais c'est aussi bien qu'on
en parle plus ce so
plusjet félicit pourquoi un homme lambda
sur lit
[Musique]
pas je trouve que ça ne regarde pas les
gens ce qui fait de sa vie privée et ça
ne doit pas être un sujet le jour de sa
nomination qu'on se félicite de son âge
de sa jeunesse plutôt de sa sexualité on
s' as raison SAF que ça suivait ça
suivait une diffusion d'un extrait à 7 à
où il en parle lui-même et en fait tout
le contexte moi je l'ai regardé ce
passage là et tout le contexte cétait au
contraire de dire non mais il en parle
de façon très libre et ça n'est plus un
problème
justement donc en fait voilà après c'est
vrai que c'était un peu injuste la façon
dont il a été critiqué d'autant qu'il
dit un choix pour les homosexuels c'est
pas forcément un choix donc ça c'est
c'est ça qui était quand même ass mal
matière à disserter dire que c'est une
volonté d'Emmanuel Macron d'avancer et
pere qu'il l' juste pris parce qu'il
était bon
d'ailleurs exuse-moi mais si on avait
dit il l'a pris parce que il a pris
cette femme parce qu'elle est blonde et
qu'elle a des gros seins ça aurait ça
aurait fait scandale donc
crèremite mais on était dans un contexte
où en fait il voulait dire que lui il en
parlait très très librement VO vu que
seulement 54 % des 16 25 ans peuvent
donner la date de la Révolution
française qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit là
selon Opinion Way donc ils ont fait un
sondage sur ça la Révolution française
bien sûr
1515 bravo Rimon non mais c'est vrai
regardez regardez ce qu'ils ont dit
regardez le mois dernier une enquête sur
le niveau scolairire des élèves a fait
bondir certains Français les résultats
sont mauvais pour l'ensemble des pays
mais tout particulièrement pour la
France et aujourd'hui un sondage Opinion
Way qui a interrogé des jeunes âgés de
16 à 24 ans inquièent plus que jamais
car selon cette étude seulement 54 %
d'entre eux connaissent la date de la
Révolution française quand je posé la
question sur qu'est-ce que c'est que le
14 juillet ils m'ont dit c'est un jour
férier c'est la fin de la guerre voilà
ils savent pas un sondage qui révèle
aussi que 32 % de ces jeunes ignorent ce
qu'est la Choa déclare pour certains ne
pas connaître la date de la chute du mur
de Berlin et celle de l'abolition de la
peine de mort et montre des lacunes en
termees de laïcité retour sur
l'inquiétante baisse du niveau des
Français ce soir dans T
PMP ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais moi je suis pas du tout
inquiet on s'en fout des dates il faut
le dire aux jeunes les dates c'est fini
l'histoire c'est pas des dates c'est des
mentalités c'est comprendre les
événements mais il faut arrêter là c'est
les vieux qui
parlent viux par ne pas savoir ce que
c'est cl ne pas savoir ce que c'est la
solution finale ne pas savoir B attends
excuse-moi mais c'est un problème mais
non on s'en fout des dates effectivement
mais c'est pas seulement oui mais c'est
pas seulement les dates ça veut dire tu
saisas pas d'é pour savoir ce qui passe
mond c'est un symbole c'est un
symbole on s'en fout des dames dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire il y a une
chronologie c'est la chronologie qui
fait que tu peux comprendre dans ton
histoire comme dans ton histoire avec
Fatou si on prend la chronologie tu me
dois une
bague je connais pas la date mais je
connais l'événement quoi voilà voilà ça
c'est importantine ça va toi non mais je
disais que en fait g il est dans le
jeunisme il veut faire absolument jeune
donc il est prêt à dire n'importe quelle
aberration pour paraître jeune en fait
c'est débile et ça t'inquiète pas de
savoir queil y a combien il y a un il y
a un jeune sur 5 qui qui a des doutes
sur l'existence de la Choa et 4 sur 6
qui pensent que la séparation des
Églises et de l'État c'est pour nuire
aux musulmans travestissez mes propos et
ça c'est grave en 2024 je ne tolererai
plus jamais ça franchement j'en ai
mar- qui se passe tu te rebelles
ton rebelle non mais c'est quoi ça
contre vous jamais non mais tu as le
droitas le droit s de complot comme ça
de méconnaissance la choix on nous dit
abruti maintenant je vais le dire entre
les autres guignoles avec leur date et
vous qui travestissez mes propos moi
c'est fini en 202 exusei excuse-moi tu
as passé une mauvaise nuit
toi non mais si tu commences à t'énerver
pour ça qu'est-ce que tu vas faire à la
fin de l'émission jours en fait donc tu
penses
quoi mais fondamentalement
fondamentalement disnous le fond de ta
pensée les dates je m'en fous non mais
arrête de rester scotché au dates là on
te parle de méconnaissance il s'en fout
plus plus globalement enlève les dates
enlève les dates et les babouches non
mais le fait le fait que dans ce Sondag
on comprend à travers ce sondage que les
jeunes ne s'intéressent pas à l'histoire
et à ce qu' peut fait ce qui fait
sociéress sur TikTok en fait de manière
horizontale comme ça sans
savoir mais non c'est pas bien chaque
génération et chaque génération a sa
culture je parle pas des dates
importantes comme la Révolution
française ou Laou la cha ils ont aussi
40 ans d'histoire si un décalage d'une
quarantaine d'années entre une
génération et une autre ils ont 40 ans
d'histoirees supplémentaire à apprendre
donc la culture de la génération n'est
pas la même que celle 4 ou 50 ans fa
avec son temps
auss la ch pas
ex ça éta peut-être important il y a
quelques années qui seront anecdoti dans
le
futur franchement
leses on s'en fout on va parler un tout
petit peu foot dans ce louper puisque le
parisgermain souhaite racheter le Parc
des Princes ils ont bien raison mais le
problème c'est que le stade appartient à
la M Paris ça c'est la tuile qui refuse
catégoritement cette idée et le
président du club Nasser que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs mon ami Nasser euh
c'estadresser directement à dalgo avant
de voir l'extrait sachez que je suis
toujours d'accord avec Nasser et je suis
toujours d'accord avec mes amis moi
aussi donc nasser est mon ami donc je
serai toujours d'accord avec lui et je
pense qu'il a grandement raison dans ce
qu'il a dit c'était chez Jérôme roten tu
embrasses d'ailleurs Jérôme aussi qui
est excellent Jérôme je t'ai oublié mais
je fait que tu m'as demandé un truc j'ai
complètement oublié rappelle-moi demain
vas-y merci non mais c'est vra Paris
joint au a fait des déclarations
récentes en disant ça me poserait un
problème que Paris vende le parc au
Qatar je m'opposerai à toute vend c'est
David Bard qui a dit ça Sud Radio c'est
à la charge du PSG de faire des travaux
ils ont suffisamment de moyens parce
queon est Qatar parce queon est Arab je
B ça c'est pas bien pens que c'est pour
ça qu' dit ça Dav je pense même
légalement on peut pas dire ça c'est
vraiment c'est grave pour moi ça
vraiment m'a fait très mal on est en
France on est de la freedom je pense ça
c'est vraiment très grave nasserfi que
j'embrasse d'ailleurs Nasser et qui a
tout à fait raisonç ils sont pas loin de
refuser la vente au Qatar s'ils le
vendent et que le Qatar et que Naser
veut acheter le le Parc des Princes ils
seront obligés de le vendre si il le met
le prix qu'ils ont demandé donc voilà
donc je vais vous dire mais surtout on
comprend pas bien la l'attitude de la
maie de Paris puisqu'ils étaient prêt
ils étaient prêts à le vendre il y a
quelques temps et ils ont complètement
changé d' et de toute façon et de toute
façon plus généralement ça ça n'a aucun
intérêt que les Mair conserent les stad
ème France c'est pour les CLS de foot
puissentir beaucoup plus puissant ils
ont besoin des stades Paris c'est vra
ailleurs on vend pas la tour on pas l'
tri
on FAM bijou de familleis GA le stade
Vélodrome il a coûté 250 millions
d'euros le rové ça coûte de l'argent si
c'est pas un investisseur nappartiendra
plus au Qatar alors on Fa quoi tu vas
demander à tous les marseillais de payer
pour des pour des rénovations
il a dit il a déclaré David Bard David
Béard il a déclaré j'assume le fait que
jepposerai à la vente de ce patrimoine
parisien et je su je suis d'accord selon
lui le traité de raciste relève de la
diffamation et ben écoutez je suis
complètement d'accord avec
Nass démolir du tout la seule chose que
je veux démolir ici c'est
G
je rigole je rigole et c'est bon c'est
bon calmez-vous merci allez vous
parlerez demain chez vous euh merci